I'm not done yet
you know element if opening the jar is a
man's job and you can't do it that's
actor Jeffrey Owens in his breakout role
as Alvin Thibodeau I never knew his last
name on The Cosby Show Owens as you may
remember made headlines in September
after he was photographed on a job
shamed you could say for working at
Trader Joe's supermarkets celebrities
like Tyler Perry immediately came to his
defense and some even offered him jobs
tomorrow night Owens will guest her on
an episode of the CBS series NCIS New
Orleans he plays commander Calvin Atkins
a friend of Special Agent Dwayne pride
I've even sleeping a couple hours every
night if I'm lucky most nights I'm not
well flashbacks nightmares sleeping
disturbances it's all textbook PTSD also
what my neurologist said your body has
healed but your mind still playing
catch-up and you're gonna tell me I need
therapy and you're gonna tell me you
don't have time Jeffy Owens back on TV
but this morning he is here at our table
it's always good to see you Jeff nice to
be here so after that picture came out
in September number one did you even
know you were being photographed and
what was your initial reaction you know
I didn't know I was being photographed
had no idea I heard I got me tipped off
that the story was gonna happen but I
you know I braced myself steeled myself
how bad is it gonna be and of course
when it came out it was worse than I'd
ever imagined just the worst photograph
of me what do you think about this story
because the woman was clearly trying to
embarrass you into me well I don't I
don't know I don't know what the woman's
motivation was I tend to think that she
just kind of in the moment thought it
would be a neat thing to do to you know
take the picture and maybe let people
know that I was there I know every night
I don't ascribe such evil motives to her
as some people do I think he's
apologized just she's apologized I
appreciate that and I forgiven her and
I'm nothing against her it was just a
kind of a stupid thing to do a bad
judgment call
the moment which I've done plenty of
things like that myself not necessarily
in that kind but you know plenty of
things and I would hope to be forgiven
so I totally forgive her but the news
agencies that sought to exploit the
story for the sake of appealing to our
worse or nature's I do not so readily
forgive but you were concerned I just
say amen to everything you just said oh
yeah sure people should go back and
rewind and watch everything you just
said because what happened what you went
through is chewing through our culture
from beginning to end and your sense of
forgiveness and also you're pointing the
finger at the people who tried to make a
big deal out of it is an amazing act of
grace in you know what was not that
great a circumstance thank you for
saying so but there was a land there was
a lot of support that came pouring in
right on the way I think about what
Terry Crews tweeted you know he said I
swept floors after the NFL I was amazed
to hear that that was hard for me to get
my head around like really so yeah it
made me I didn't feel so bad other
people have been where I have been you
know and other people will be where I am
and this is a universal thing we're
talking about the distant Manas essa T
of working and the nobility of work but
your concern wasn't about working at
Trader Joe's you just wanted people to
know I still want to act right I'm
worried about that the reason I didn't
want it to get out generally that I was
at Trader Joe's not anything having to
be ashamed of
working at Trader Joe's which is a great
place to work as a matter of fact and
they were very good to me but just that
I didn't want the it my industry the
entertainment industry to without having
the full story to think well he's not in
the industry anymore he's given up on
acting in fact that nothing could be
further from the truth in fact while I
was at Trader Joe's I actually booked
for television jobs so I've never
stepped out and I didn't want to give
that impression how do you like we're an
NCIS oh it's great
it was great they were so nice to me
like immediate family like instant
family just like Tyler Perry's people in
Atlanta yeah I appreciate about you like
a king I've never been treated so nice
do we dare think recurring role on NCIS
or I don't know someone mentioned that
but you know would you like that yeah
that would be great
we love recurring yeah
you know I've been in this business a
long time so you know you learn when you
hear certain things you take it in you
hope for the best and and you kind of
move on you don't necessarily you don't
assume anything is true that you hear
yes but that would be nice and and if
not that opportunity that one time that
show is great and you know are you still
working at Trader Joe's I'm not actually
I'm on indefinite leave that in fact I
went in the other day I still shop there
one day and I talked to my old boss I
was a great guy and I actually said you
know I said you guys you guys will take
me back right if I need to come back oh
yeah yeah I think a lot of people take
me back I think John's right to point
out the heart that you have
nicely done Geoffrey thank you guys
things you can watch Geoffrey on NCIS
New Orleans at tomorrow at 10:00 9:00
central right here on yes yes